hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
question what the fuck is up with
weather while things are the children's
book about a boy who makes believe he
goes to an island of monsters is
celebrated by kids and families
everywhere so in the film was coming out
with its dark gritty look and held by
acclaimed director Spike Jonze people
got excited as hell and after it finally
premiered what did the pub would think
huh
it wasn't hated but it wasn't loved
either people just didn't know what to
think of it my opinion personally not
only do I think it was an incredible
movie but I think it's one of the best
films to come out of the past few
decades why because I think it best
understands more than any other film the
dramatic and potent mindset of a child
psychology what do I mean by that
pretentiousness well let's look at the
boy's life
we know his parents are separated we
know his sister cares for him but
doesn't always show and while trying to
keep up with appearances his mother
looks after him but is trying to have a
life of her own and he is more than an
emotional handful oh and we also know
one of their important element he's
extremely imaginative to a point where
he creates worlds to retreat to and
other features to interact with and in
the middle of one of his more emotional
moments he stays in one of his fantasy
worlds and decides he wants to stay
there possibly forever now this is where
most people start to get confused the
world he lives in doesn't make a whole
lot of sense for example they'll just
beat stuff up run around like crazy and
only say things like he gets it or did
you know the son was gonna die yeah
strange conversations and dialogues that
have little to no segues in fact most of
the world has no segways one minute
they're in the forest the next they're
in the desert but in order to really
understand this I ask you to go back to
when you were a kid not when you were
with friends not when you were watching
TV but when you were all alone
no matter who we were there was always a
time when we wanted to be alone why we
wanted to figure stuff out
but the twist is we didn't know that we
were figuring stuff out we thought we
were only being sad or being happy or
just playing a lot of times though we're
trying to make sense of things and the
way many kids do that is through
imagination
sometimes we talked to a friend other
times we talked to our toys but we
forget to that many times we simply talk
to ourselves we made up places we could
go and people we could talk to and it
isn't just really lonely kids that did
this every kid did this at some point
they could be obvious like if somebody
did something we didn't like we could
imagine big revenge or if we thought
ugly we could imagine ourselves looking
beautiful obvious fix it up scenarios
but sometimes we didn't know how to feel
what to do or who to turn to and in some
of those instances we just made up
places and people to bounce our emotions
off of the worlds and scenarios didn't
always make sense but they didn't have
to you weren't trying to tell a story
perform a piece or please anyone this
was your world to look and feel however
you want it to look and feel and because
of that the world you create often runs
on more emotion and less logic this is
the world our main character has created
when he wants to feel accepted he'll
create a scenario where he's accepted
when he wants to play he'll create a
scenario where he plays if he's tired
after playing he'll have all his new
friends take a nap with them their
justification lies in whatever mood he's
in I think the best way to explain this
is imagine these characters being
replaced with something you strongly
connected with as a kid like maybe Ninja
Turtles or Barbie or life with Louie I
don't know I'm sure somebody watch that
it's your comfort zone where you know
you can go no matter how you feel now
keeping that in mind what happens in the
movie the kid runs away to his fantasy
world and at first it's great but slowly
the world starts to turn against him
suddenly things go sad and bitter
there's no logical reason why it just
seems like everything that should be
good is suddenly falling apart and
that's one of the great things about the
movie it doesn't make it obvious what
everything
is it's not like one monster represents
his dad or another monster represents
his mom or sister you could argue
there's heavy leanings towards them but
no one creation represents one element
for example Carol could be a mix of his
father his own insecurities his fears
his hopes and the feelings are the exact
same way they're not spelled out maybe
the kid can be feeling something as
basic as he just wants to return home
even though it's not perfect and can be
painful sometimes but he doesn't know
that's what he's going through he just
knows a world that was supposed to be
great is now turning angry and cold and
he's coming to his own realizations of
how to feel with the troubles going on
in his life this is pretty much the kids
therapy
it's how he gets through his problems
and all of us have had a time where this
is how we got through our problems as
well we just didn't know that's what we
were doing because of that the movie
doesn't hit you on the head with it it
wets the emotions to find the reality
and I bet if you really give yourself to
what this kid is feeling you'll remember
very similar and powerful emotions the
same you had as a child - just because
the worlds and characters you created
weren't real doesn't mean the emotions
you felt weren't real either they were
very real so real that they almost felt
solid and that's what this movie does it
gives you that solid world where your
emotions combined with your imagination
some films do have a similar emphasis on
emotion
like Wizard of Oz draws much from your
hopes and dreams as well as your fears
and nightmares and a lot of early Disney
films would put logic aside to fulfill
those emotional needs as well and if you
remember being really young and watching
those movies you'll remember there was a
time where you didn't always comprehend
what was going on but you understood
what the characters were feeling and
going through almost like they spoke a
language that was purely emotion but as
you got older you realize they did have
stories that for the most part lived in
a logical world where the wild things
are invites you back to that realm where
the logic didn't matter hell it barely
existed it lived in dreams desires
uneasiness uncertainty pain happiness
and everything else that your mind could
conjure up but didn't know
to do with it was a very real part of
our lives that we often forget we went
through and this movie is here to remind
us not only how important that time in
our lives was but that it should never
be forgotten and it'll always be there
to bring us back to that place where the
wild romp is started door maybe it's
just much a crazy shit I don't know I'm
a nostalgic credit guy remember it so
you don't have to
you